écologie réindustrialisation emploi on
connaît donc un les priorités du plan de
relance tant attendue de l'économie
française c'est l'un des derniers à être
dévoilés en europe alors ce plan est il
à la hauteur des enjeux qu'elle dépense
véritablement nouvelle contient-il on en
parle tout de suite avec l'économiste
jacques sapir et bienvenue jacques
bienvenu olivier merci alors dites-nous
tour que contient donc ce plan de
relance alors oui on a raison on a
présenté ce plan quand un plan etc c'est
excessivement ambitieux et c'est vrai
qu'avec 100 milliards d'euros il y à une
somme qui en apparence est tout à fait
considérable
après il faut comprendre que ce plan est
nécessaire parce que l'économie
française est actuellement exsangue il y
a eu évidemment les deux mois de
confinement
il ya certes eu un petit rebond après le
confinement mais on voit et en
particulier sur les chiffres du mois
d'août choix les chiffres de l'activité
du mois d'août on voit que l'activité
est en train de retomber
et donc il faut absolument relancer
cette activité
alors c'est un plan important mais c'est
un plan qui d'une certaine manière
mélange des dépenses mais aussi tout
simplement des abattements d'impôts donc
des déductions fiscales
or ces déductions fiscales les fameuses
impôts sur la production
eh bien ce sont des ressources pour les
collectivités locales et donc il faudra
d'une certaine manière les compenser et
tout cela
d'une certaine manière ne contribue pas
à la lisibilité de la politique du
gouvernement en voyons tout cela plus en
détail jacques quels sont les grands
axes de ce plan alors ces grands axes il
était en réalité connue depuis la fin
juin ou le début juillet on peut même
remonter de ce point de vue là au projet
de loi de finances rectificative qui
avait été publiée au mois de juin il ya
tout d'abord évidemment une priorité
pour la transition énergétique vous
l'avais dit avant cette priorité elle va
compter pour à peu près 30 milliards il
y a ensuite le
le volet je dirais compétitivité et
aides aux entreprises et c'est là où on
a d'une certaine manière 15 milliards
d'argent frais et 20 milliards de
déductions fiscales
et puis on a aussi ce fameux volet sur
la solidarité et l'emploi
un volet qui est un espèce de grand
fourre tout et qui pose d'ailleurs toute
une série de problèmes de ce point de
vue là il est clair que le premier
ministre s'est engagé d'une certaine
manière à lutter contre la montée du
chômage que l'on va connaître un d'ici
la fin de l'année et il espère que ce
plan va pouvoir créer 160 mille nouveaux
emplois mais c'est très peu par rapport
à l'ensemble des emplois qui seront
détruits alors concernant le projet de
loi de finances rectificative at on
avancé sur ce point alors vous rappeler
que j'avais présenté justement ce projet
de loi de finances dans l'émission au
mois de juin
oui on a assurément avancées de ce point
de vue là alors ce projet si vous voulez
il avait à l'époque trois priorités le
tourisme l'industrie aéronautique et
l'industrie automobile qu'est ce qu'on
constate maintenant on constate tout
d'abord le fait que dans la question
énergétique et et bien il y à là toute
une série de dépenses hawaï évidemment
les dépenses qui vont importer sur la
rénovation et l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments
il y a un gros secteur du transport qui
contient ce qu'on appelle le plan sncr
un plan qui en réalité avait déjà été
discuté à la fin du mois de juin et au
début du mois de juillet et qui n'est
pas nouveau de ce point de vue là mais
bref c'est néanmoins un plan important
et puis on a les plans sur les
différentes mobilité il ya aussi la
question des énergies vertes et quelque
chose d'un petit peu nouveau une toute
petite partie pour l'agriculture après
la le deuxième volet la deuxième grande
priorité c'est évidemment reconstruire
la compétitivité de l'économie française
et permettre justement des
relocalisations
alors c'est là où on voit
il y a un problème puisque sur les 35
milliards y en a 20 qui ne sont pas de
l'argent c'est en réalité des
abattements d'impôts et qui plus est des
abattements d'impôts qui sont répartis
sur deux ans 10 milliards en 2021 10
milliards en 2022 ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que sur un sujet qui est
un vrai sujet si vous voulez qu'il est
un sujet important ce qui est la
question des fonds propres des
entreprises
il n'y a que 3 milliards et ça c'est
très largement insuffisant et puis on a
le troisième volet est alors comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure il s'agit d'un
espèce de pot pourri de différentes
mesures alors bien sûr il ya le plan des
jeunes pour l'emploi c'est justement sur
ce plan que compte
jean castex pour essayer non pas
d'inverser mais de freiner la montée du
chômage
il y a les sommes qui seront à nouveau
accordé au chômage partiel et qui ne
devrait pas figurer en réalité dans ce
plan car il ne s'agit pas de mesures de
relance il s'agit de mesures
d'accompagnement dans la crise il y a
bien entendu une petite aide pour les
collectivités locales
5 milliards mais ces 5 milliards sont
loin de compenser les 20 milliards que
les collectivités locales vont perdre
avec la suppression des impôts de
production et puis on retrouve les
grosso modo six milliards qu'ils avaient
déjà été prévues ils ont été négociés
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé donc
on le voit c'est un mélange finalement
assez hétéroclite
alors l'on les sommes sont elles plus
importante que ce qui avait été déjà
prévu en juin alors oui ça c'est
absolument incontestable en juin on
était plutôt sûr qu'à rome 3 milliards
on est là techniquement sur 100
milliards encore faut-il préciser que
les 43 milliards du mois de juin
c'était de l'argent frais et que on a à
100 milliards d'argent frais on a en
réalité 80 milliards si on enlève déjà
les impôts de production qui seront
supprimés et puis il ya toute une
série de plans qui ont été inclus dans
ce plan de relance
des sommes qui étaient déjà prévus par
exemple on savait déjà
début juillet qu'il faudrait prolonger
le chômage partiel
ça a été rajouté et donc si on fait le
total menacer pas 100 milliards d'argent
frais
c'est 63 milliards à peu prêt d'argent
frais alors bien sûr c'est plus que les
43 milliards qui avait été prévu au mois
de juin mais on voit bien que l'on reste
quand même en deçà de ce qui est fait
par nos voisins par exemple l'allemagne
elle prévoit 130 milliards et même la
grande bretagne et l'italie prévoit en
réalité plus que nous mais il y a aussi
une spécificité dans la méthode n'est ce
pas oui et ça c'est un point qui est
d'ailleurs intéressant alors pour dire
les choses
jean castex vous degré créer ce qu'on
appelle des sous-préfets justement
chargé du plan de relance l'idée et est
assez simple ça consiste à dire voilà il
y aura des gens qui seront dans les
régions ils seront dans les préfectures
dans chaque département et qui pourront
vérifier que les choses qui sont décidés
à paris sont bien appliquées dans les
départements voient pourront faire
remonter toute une série de demandes
vers paris quand les mesures en
jouissant des problèmes d'application
alors en théorie c'est excellent sauf
que il est aussi précisée par lang a
fait il ne s'agira de jeunes hauts
fonctionnaires et ça déjà ça pose un
véritable problème des jeunes hauts
fonctionnaires sont des gens qui
manquent d'expérience par définition ce
sont des gens qui seront donc beaucoup
plus sensibles on peut même dire
vulnérables tout d'abord à
l'accumulation des demandes venant des
différents acteurs mais aussi aux
pressions il faut bien comprendre que il
ya toute une série d'entreprises qui
feront un lobbying important pour
obtenir plus et donc cela risque
d'aboutir à une forme de saupoudrage du
camp et il faut savoir le saupoudrage
c'est toujours l'un des grands périls
qui guettent les plans de l'état
alors on peut se demander effectivement
pourquoi n'at-on pas fait un guichet
unique
pourquoi n'at-on pas réinstaller ce
système qui avait fonctionné en fait
lors de la crise de 2008 à 2010 ou pour
régler l'ensemble des problèmes et bien
les entreprises ont un seul
interlocuteur et ça ça pose un véritable
problème problème donc me jean castex et
probablement conscient puisque il a
insisté sur le fait que la
simplification administrative serait
justement au coeur de la réussite de ce
plan
c'est indiscutable et il faut de ce
point de vue la lui rendre
acte du fait qu'il a en tous les cas
identifié le problème
alors pour conclure jacques terray
finalement votre sentiment sur ce plan
qui vient d'être dévoilée
je vous cache pas que mon sentiment est
assez mitigé il est tout d'abord mitigé
parce que dans l' annonce on voit bien
que ce plan mélange des choses qui sont
bonnes
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
discutable et surtout on a le sentiment
qu'il y a une forme d' habillage
politique une forme de communication
politique dans le plan ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est un
petit malaise quand même sur les sommes
pourquoi parle-t-on de 100 milliards
alors qu'il n'ya pas 100 milliards
d'argent frais pourquoi at on voulu
ajouter dans le plan justement pour
atteindre ces fameux 100 milliards des
choses qui avaient déjà été décidées qui
était déjà prévue et qui ne devrait pas
normalement faire partie du plan donc
tout ceci crée un petit malaise brouille
un petit peu l'image que voudrait donner
le gouvernement
avec ce plan fait peser un doute réel
sur l'efficacité globale de ce plan et
on sait par exemple que les déductions
d'impôts c'est pas très efficace on l'a
vérifié si vous voulez sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande avec la
fameuse affaire du crédit impôt du cic
eux mais bref je pense que il faut de ce
point de vue là attendre voir comment
les choses se mettront en place on peut
penser d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
on pourrait corriger et d'ailleurs son
plan est s'il voyait qu'il y avait des
problèmes au niveau de l'exécution et
donc de ce point de vue là laissons
faire un petit peu le temps et bien
merci beaucoup jacky vous aurez bien
évidemment l'occasion de revenir nous en
parler dans les prochains mois